what's going on guys today we're going
to be doing a kill count for the final
season of attack on titan
as the title suggests we'll be going
through each episode from the first half
of the final season
and estimating how many people were
straight up killed by aaron or whoever
else it may be
by this point antagon titan is pretty
notorious for the amount of people who
seem to die
every season so we will reach a fairly
high number by the end of this video
but remember that these are all still
rough estimations along the way i'll
likely be rounding the numbers up if i'm
unsure how many people died
but other than that it will be as
accurate as it can be before we begin be
sure to smash that sub button for more
content like this
and drop a like as i do really
appreciate it okay so starting with
episode 1
this dropped us straight in the middle
of a war zone where eldian soldiers were
getting destroyed left and right
we had around 10 casualties that we saw
in between falco waking up and cult
dragging him to the trenches
and the grash brothers were lucky to
survive considering what happened to the
guys next to them
in total there were still 800 soldiers
remaining at this point and if it hadn't
been for gabby's quick thinking then a
lot more of them would have been added
to the kill count
by doing what she did with these hand
grenades one enemy soldier was taken out
while the other was finished off by
poco's jaw titan that however did not
stop the losses completely
since i reckon about 200 soldiers were
wiped out during their charge against
these machine guns
in this charge the allied forces did
lose a few people themselves but it was
nothing compared to when it started
raining titans
once zeke did its thing a lot of them
were crushed immediately and many of
them that survived were eaten just as
fast
it should be mentioned that at least
half the titans didn't survive this fall
and i will add that to the kill count
because they are technically still real
human beings
anyhow the remaining titans were
gradually destroyed by cannons but the
arma titan avenged their deaths by going
on a rampage of his own
by the time he and galiad were done
there must have been only a handful of
lucky survivors within force lava
as the rest were either crushed or
turned into titanfood episode 1 ended
with the arrival of the beast titan who
only added to the misery of the allied
forces by destroying their entire fleet
destroying those ships was the whole
purpose of capturing force lava
and in doing so marley had won the war
after four years
moving over to episode two of the final
season there was only one death which
occurred not long after the battle
itself
once they all got back to liberia many
alien soldiers were completely
traumatized
while others were plotting out to blow
the place sky-high one of the aliens
with ptsd jumped off his roof that same
night
followed by a crowd gathered around his
body the next morning this death was
never in the source material
so the anime went a bit further in
showing us just how much elding soldiers
were suffering
episode 3 picked up the pace in a big
way beginning with the brutal
assassination of this grasshopper who
was just minding his business until
annie came along
she continued the carnage by wiping out
a tower full of soldiers once she
inherited the female titan
and this was all part of a flashback to
mali's invasion of another country
all the other warriors were also
involved in some way as zeke's pitching
assault came in handy
and marcel did a fair bit of damage
himself it should be no surprise that
berto had the highest body count of this
particular episode
given that his colossal obliterated an
entire military base
the next person to die was marcel after
being eaten by yamiya's draw titan
and this scene gave us a perspective on
why he felt the need to save reiner
the colossal titan then smashed in war
maria but i'm not going to count these
deaths because it is effectively season
1 animation that we're looking at
a death i will acknowledge though is the
man who oft himself after telling the
warriors his story
and rhino was a couple seconds away from
following in his footsteps
if it wasn't for falco hitting the wall
at the end of this episode then the vice
captain would likely have been added to
that number in the corner
episode 4 was one of very few to have no
death whatsoever i mean the closest we
got was poker nearly having a heart
attack but beyond that there was nothing
new
driege did have a very brief flashback
about his daughter but that doesn't
really count because we already had the
full context around her death
and we don't even really see her in this
flashback the declaration of war was
episode 5
and although aaron got a mountain of
kills here it all came in the last 30
seconds of the run time
his first victims were the innocent
aliens who lived in the housing behind
the main stage
and if you look at the remains i'm gonna
say there was something like 50 to 100
people living here
willie tiber was the highest profile
casualty but unlike the others aaron
actually took the time to eat his
remains
this was an attempt to inherit the
warmer titan's power however on this
occasion he ate the wrong type of
sibling
the kill count increased in the
following episode when we had several
bystanders like zafia who were crushed
by rocks
and others like udo who died in the
stampede the attack titan then body
slammed the leaders of mali's military
which was easily over 100 people
before repeatedly punching that spot to
ensure no one survived in a strange way
aaron was angry at them for what they
forced elding soldiers to go through
yet he himself similarly is okay with
killing aliens to fulfill his own goals
lara tiber was the next victim of his
merciless beatdown and their fight had
significant collateral damage
when she stabbed the attack titan it
sent tons of debris flying into the air
killing the local drunk in the process
and i'm sure many other innocent
civilians
for the rest of this particular episode
it was the malia soldiers who suffered
the most
as they were taken out by thunderspears
grenades and even odm gear
in this scene we had multiple vehicles
carrying soldiers only for them all to
be blown apart a second later
the two guards that gabby liked were
both shot from the rooftop by sasha
while gabby herself was completely
spared it's worth noting the reason
there are so many soldiers is because
command magath ordered 30
000 to head towards liberia many
soldiers were arriving as part of a
naval fleet
which appeared to have at least 11 ships
at the time if we're generous and assume
that there are more ships than just this
and that each ship has 300 soldiers then
roughly there should be at least 5 000
troops at the port
that info will be relevant soon but the
thing we should focus on for now
is that only six scouts died in episode
seven those kills came from the draw
titan panzer unit and commander mcgath
himself
and if we consider that the scout's plan
was for these two shifters to be trapped
underground
it's almost a miracle that only six
soldiers died after their unexpected
escape
the animation switches over to the port
where the thousands of malian troops
that i spoke about begin to arrive
armin disguised himself among the ships
and once he was ready he unleashed the
single biggest kill for this half of the
season
his colossal explosion was likely the
biggest one he could produce
as it sent warships flying into the sky
this turned the surrounding area into a
barren wasteland and i'd estimate 15
000 people were wiped out either by the
actual blast or from the flying debris
of course that's just my personal guess
so let me know down below what you think
armen's body count might be
in terms of dying the panzer unit were
the next to go with sasha ending one of
them with a rifle
while the others got thunderspeared
alongside the car titan itself
the final kill of this episode was by
far the most valuable given that aaron
broke lara tyber out of her crystal
and consumed the warhammer titan up till
then the crystals seemed indestructible
but pogo inadvertently showed everyone
that it could be damaged by the draw
titan in episode 8 we got two additional
deaths for the survey corps
both of which were directly caused by
gabby her initial kill was commander
lobov who was a guy that transferred
from the garrison to the scouts
and he actually had the chance to shoot
her but hesitated due to her age
after killing him gabby used his odm
gear to travel onto the airship
and we all know what happens after that
just like the commander
sasha previously underestimated what
gabby could do which enabled the warrior
candidate to pick up a weapon and begin
her killing spree
as a character we've known from the
early early days the death of sasha was
the most hard-hitting
and one of the few times that hobo aaron
showed emotion moving on to episode 9
the only person who died was an officer
in the malian army as he was
assassinated by elena
she did this on orders from zeke and
after that moment she was the main
middleman between the people from
paradise and the marlin volunteers
the next episode had a total of zero
deaths but we still got some iconic
moments
including this exchange about who should
inherit the attack titan and the reveal
of historia's pregnancy
episode 11 also didn't have many
casualties with the only fatality being
this soldier who gaby smashed with a
brick
gaby lured him into the cell by
pretending she was having a seizure
making this the fourth time she had
killed a person who had shown some level
of concern for her
safety episode 12 had a minimum of four
kills
after the aegis planted an explosive
inside zachary's torture device
the resulting blast took out zachary
himself who was the head of all three
military branches
and it also eliminated these three
members of the military police
those three mps were candidates to
inherit the founding titan from eren
which is exactly why the yeagers wanted
to get rid of them
if we're being technical there were
still a few more deaths if you count the
brief flashback where on yank upon
exposure in his past
but we didn't really know those
characters but i'll include them anyway
the 13th episode of the season was
another with zero casualties
with the closest death coming when gabby
nearly got stabbed if it wasn't for
mikasa
in the following episode zeke turned 30
soldiers into abnormal titans with his
scream
and a situation like this would kill
anyone who wasn't superhuman
29 of the titans were killed by the
captain himself while the final one was
torn apart by the beast titan
as he used its body parts in place of
the rocks he would normally have
amazingly though that final titan is not
added to the kill count because it did
somehow survive
in episode 16 it reappeared to shove
zeke inside his stomach
but since this is a spoiler free video i
won't go into details of whether he or
levi survived the thunderspear explosion
in terms of the remaining deaths for the
first half of the final season there
were still quite a few in the last
episode grize was a malian volunteer who
betrayed nikolo's trust by calling the
jaegers and in doing so elena gave him a
more powerful position
that promotion would not last long
though as after he insulted sasha's
memory one too many times
elena kills him without hesitation the
final casualties were this room full of
soldiers which i estimate to be around
20 to 30 people
poco had managed to blend in with these
guys but once he did this
pretty much all of them would have died
the titan transformation itself would
have wiped out those standing next to
him
and the falling bricks would have likely
taken care of the rest
with that said we have now completed the
kill camp for now but something tells me
the second half of the season might just
be this number by a little bit
i mean who knows if you enjoyed this
video then please drop a like and hit
that sub button
as well so you don't miss my new uploads
until the next one
peace out